foreign
[Music]
sorry that I can't attend the RCT
conference in person this year but I
guess you won't miss anything from this
talk with my absence well if you really
miss my face you can simply Google for
my picture and stare at it for 20
minutes along with this talk so there
are people who are really familiar with
my talk and my previous talks and work
on the so-called dong packages they are
still familiar that every time they meet
me they don't greet me with the usual
WhatsApp instead they say what's down
well this time I'm not going to talk
about any down packages I won't let you
down as usual
um so what's down nothing is down what's
up quarto is up
um so most down packages have had or
will have equivalents in quarto which
you might have heard for several times
at this conference
and I need to I probably should clarify
that the down packages won't be down
anytime soon we will continue to
maintain them so why am I talking about
meter today because the Knitter package
is a common Cornerstone of quarto in our
markdown so both of them are built on
top of Knitter so you can apply what you
have learned today about Knitter in this
talk to both quarto and our markdown
documents so Knitter has existed for a
little over 10 years so the development
started in 2011.
and I made the first crani release in
January 2012 over these years I have
made more than 50 Grand releases and
there have been more than two 5 000
questions on stack of overflow in more
than 2 000 GitHub issues and pull
requests I I would also like to thank
all the Knitter contributors and there
are more than 100 of them since the
pandemic I have almost lost track of
time
so basically I want to look back and see
what I have done
in the past two years whether I have
done anything meaningful so as I said
nitter is over 10 years old so it has
become quite mature and probably
inevitably boring as time goes by you
know when things become mature they
often become boring too just like adults
you know the keys are much more fun yeah
for software
being mature is not bad it's actually a
good thing in this talk I'm not I'm not
going to I'm not going to talk about any
like totally exciting new features
because there are not any huge new
features in recent years in the in the
development of Knitter but I would like
to highlight a few little things so for
a full list of changes and new features
you can check out the release notes of
Knitter later so the first thing I want
to highlight is that now you have a new
way to write chunk options previously
you must write all chunk options on one
line in the chunk header but now you can
write them on multiple lines as special
comments in the beginning of the chunk
body
so this special comments start with the
hash character followed by the pipe
character I'm not sure how would you
pronounce this combination
maybe Hash Pipe I remember someone
mentioned me that Hash Pipe was a funny
coincidence
since I'm not a native English speaker I
had no idea what Hash Pipe means so I
Googled for that and I regret it anyway
Hash Pipe comments you can use that to
write chunk options
so as I said previously you have to
force all the chunk options onto a
single line which is sometimes very
awkward if you have many many
chunk options for a single chunk there
will be an awkward uh horizontal screw
bar but now you can write all of your
chunk options can write with your chunk
body you can put them inside the chunk
after the special comments and you can
also hard wrap all these lines freely
you can you can write them on any number
of lines for example you can put one
chunk option on one line or you can like
break a single chunk option in the
middle you can wrap them in any way you
like and alternatively you can also use
the yaml syntax to provide your chunk
options
so previously I'm showing the old syntax
of comma separated chunk options of the
form option equals value
and separated by commas if you are
familiar with yamo you know that syntax
will be option colon followed by value
and you have to write one option per
line
and for quarto in R Studio or vs code
users I strongly recommend that you use
the yaml syntax because the editors are
studio and vs code they have better
support for the yaml options for example
they can help you out complete the
option names they can validate the
values of your options and second the
yaml syntax works for other engines in
quarto as well such as Jupiter so if you
want to convert from convert the old
syntax to the new syntax there's a
function named convert chunk header in
knitter
so you can use that function to convert
your old markdown documents to to using
the new syntax for chunk options this
requires a very recent version of
Knitter in the second thing I want to
talk about is how to reuse chunk both
chunk options in chunk content from
other codes chunks so previously there
existed several ways to reuse the
content of a code chunk for example
through the ref dot label option so
suppose you have one code chunk with the
label chunk a and then you can write
another code chunk with the label chunk
B but set the chunk option ref dot label
equals chunk a and ref down label
equals chunk a that means I want to cop
copy
the chunk content of Chunk a into chunk
B so now although you see the chunk B is
empty here but when you execute the
this document
um junk B will have the same content as
chunk a you can learn more about
reusing the chunk content in the our
markdown cookbook so now in addition to
reusing the content of code chunks you
can also reuse chunk options from other
code chunks
and this can be done through the chunk
option Ops dot label so for example you
have chunk a here and you have set a
couple of Chunk options on chunk a
and if you want to use the same chunk
options in chunk B then you simply need
you simply can set up start label equals
chunk a so instead of repeating all the
chunk options from chunk a you simply
set a single option ops.label equals
chunk a and then chunk B will use the
same chunk options as chunk a then if
you want to reuse
um both chunk options and the content
from other code chunks you can you can
set the chunk option ref not label to
the label of other code chunks and then
wrap the labels in the function I for
example here I have chunk a which has a
few chunk options and then it also has
some chunk content and then in chunk B I
said ref dot label equals I chunk a that
means I want to use both the content of
Chunk a and the chunk options of Chunk a
so in that way you don't have to repeat
everything from chunk a you simply set a
single option and Knitter will copy
everything to the next to to chunk B so
I also want to share two quick tips
first the chunk options ref not label
and Ops dot label can take a vector of
Chunk labels that means you can reuse a
multiple code chunks instead of a single
one
and second you can
provide further local chunk options if
you if a code chunk has some local chunk
options they will override the reused
options of the same names so in the in
this example chunk B is basically
reusing both chunk options in the chunk
content of Chunk a but it has set a
local chunk option Dev equals PNG
so since we have borrowed all the chunk
options from chunk a which uh includes
the chunk option Dev equals SVG so now
chunk B since chunk B has a local chunk
option W equals PNG this depth equals
PNG will overwrite the dev equals SVG
from chunk a
so basically
local chunk options will have higher
priorities
if you reuse chunk options from other
codes chunks third thing I want to
mention is some the new chunk options in
Knitter in recent years we have added a
few of them and but today I'm just going
to mention one of them here which is the
file option so sometimes you might you
may want to develop code in in an
external script and include it in a code
chunk previously what you could do is to
use the chunk option code so for example
here I'm using the chunk option code
that takes the value from read lines
script.r so that basically means that I
want to read an external script and pass
the content of that script to the code
option and then enter nodes okay I will
use the content of that script as the
content of this code chunk
that that's the previous way of
including external scripts into a code
chunk now this can be simplified to
the chunk option file so you can set
file equals a file path for example
script.r so basically that's equivalent
to using Code equals read lines
script.r before and this file option
also supports a vector of file paths for
example we can pass two scripts to the
file option and the file option will
read both of them into the code chunk
the fourth thing I want to highlight is
some new engines initer the first one is
comment engine so you can use the
comment engine to comment out any
content
and the content can contain basically
anything including code chunks or
include or inline R expressions or other
paragraphs or anything so basically
there's one rule that you have to
remember so if the comment contains
like three tactics and then for the
comment engine
you have to start with four backticks so
basically the rule is that if you're if
your comment contains n tactics then the
comment engine
needs to start with M plus one backtics
so one if the content is commented out
it will it it will not be included in
the output and the the second engine is
the verbatim engine and this can be very
useful when you want to write tutorials
on our markdown so and and you may want
to display some content verbatim
especially the codes chunks when you
want to display a code chunk verbatim
you can use the verbatim engine
and the rule is the same so for example
here I'm including a code chunk with
three back clicks and then the repeating
engine needs to start with four back
ticks for the verbatim engine depending
on the content of the
depending on the language of the content
you can you can set a syntax
highlighting language through the chunk
option Lan so for example here I'm using
Lan equals markdown that means okay the
verbatim content here is markdown code
but this Lang option option is optional
so it depends on whether you want to
syntax highlighting in your output for
the repeating content
and previously I have introduced some
old
ugly hacks
on how to show content repeating and now
you can forget all of them and here um I
just yeah I I don't want to explain this
anymore this is just too ugly use the
verbatim engine and forget about the old
ugly hacks
third engine that I want to show is the
embed engine you can use it's the you
can use the embed engine to embed
external files text files actually
you can embed external text files and
display their content repeat him so this
is similar to the verbatim engine but
you can use the fire option to
uh embed external files
so you don't have to write the content
in the in the chunk body you just point
the file option to some file paths and
alternatively you can write file paths
in the chunk body of the embed engine
for example you can write quote foo.r
code bar dot r
so the second way has a tiny advantage
that is if you write in the chunk body
if you write the file paths in the chunk
body your editor for example R Studio
may be able to out complete the file
paths the last engine that I want to
show here is the exact engine so this
engine
allows you to execute an arbitrary
system command on a file that contains
the content of the chunk
so that command can be specified through
the chunk option command so for example
I have an exact
engine
here and I'm using the command equals
bash that means I want to run the
command bash on
the the command that I specify
in the chunk body
so basically when when Nature sees
an exact
chunk it will write the chunk body into
a file and execute the command on that
file
so for this batch example actually you
don't have to use the exact engine you
can simply use the existing batch engine
in Knitter so these two these two cut
chunks are pretty much equivalent
there have existed a lot of
command-based engines in Knitter for
example Arc or go or Pearl or Z shell
and from now on we no longer need to add
a new engine for every single command
you can basically use the exact engine
to execute any command
and by the way the exact
engine is also extensible so you can if
you're interested you can go back and
check out the examples example on the
link through the link here so for those
who are curious about how the exact
engine works so basically uh
network will execute
a command of the form command arcs1 rx2
are sorry command args one arcs then
args2 where RX is a file path and this
file contains the content of the code
chunk and August 1 and rx2 are optional
command line arguments that you might
you may specify through the chunk option
engine.ops so here I have an example
that executes the grep command
uh with a few command line arguments
Dash I and which means case insensitive
matching and then the pattern is hhe
and I want to
execute grep on the four lines of text
here so you know h e will if you match h
e in case insensitivity it will match
the first line hello and the third line
since it has the which contains h e
and just a quick recap we have uh talked
about four things in today's talk first
thing is that you can use Hash Pipe
comments in the chunk body to write
chunk options you can then you can use
upstart label and ref not label options
to reuse both chunk options and content
and third you can use the file option to
read external files as the chunk content
and last you we have introduced a few
new engines
in knitter so that's all I have for you
today thank you very much and happy
knitting